Islam is a faith tradition that is known
it's one of the abrahamic faiths and
Allah in Aramaic means God Jesus when he
spoke Aramaic would say Allah or Elohim
went to Syrian Aramaic absolutely yeah
so it just means the same word it's the
same Source uh God I don't use there's a
word because I think it's loaded in the
English language so even in English when
I'm speaking I prefer to say Allah just
so people understand that um ultimately
we're speaking of the same subject
matter here and and Islam in in that
sense is is distinct from islamism the
desire to impose Islam over Society
Jihad coming back to those terms again
means struggle
so in the verb you could say it just
means I struggle and then of course
there are many various manifest
manifestations of struggle primarily we
are our enemies is within us and our
solution often and always actually is
within us as well